bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 22
février voici les titres de ce journal
l'amendement a été déposée la semaine
dernière au sénat puis immédiatement
rejetée par les parlementaires le
gouvernement proposait d'instaurer le
vote par anticipation pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 et de quoi
parle-t-on et pourrait-on voir sa mise
en oeuvre pour les prochains scrutins
invité jean-pierre camby professeur
associé à lui vécu et spécialiste du
droit électoral
la visite de jean baptiste djebbari sur
le plateau de satory à versailles le
ministre délégué aux transports s'est
rendu au mobile à bas la rencontre de
deux entreprises un déplacement sur le
thème du véhicule autonome secteur en
plein essor avec les premières
expérimentations en cours et puis
direction trappe à la fin de cette
édition après l'emballement médiatique
des derniers jours cette initiative
d'une habitante de la ville et du
rappeur saint quentinois kurt à un clip
musical a été tourné hier devant le
lycée de la plaine de neauphle
l'objectif redonner une image positive
de la connu du sport également à suivre
tout à l'heure avec les championnats de
france de cyclo cross qui se sont tenues
ce week-end c'était à lille le dos de l
île de loisirs je vais y arriver est de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est sans surprise que le sénat a
rejeté jeudi 18 février l'amendement
déposé par le gouvernement pour
autoriser le vote par anticipation lors
de l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
on parle de ce sujet avec célia de son
go bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78 quel
était l'objet de cet amendement et bien
selon marlène schiappa 1 la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté les électeurs
auraient pu voter de manière anticipée
sur des machines à voter durant la
semaine précédant le scrutin dans des
bureaux et aline date qui restait à
définir par décret alors l'amendement et
vous l'avez dit a définitivement
entériné par le sénat pour en tout cas à
l'élection de 2022 qu'est ce que
concrètement le vote anticipation ce
lien alors le système de vote par
anticipation peut prendre différentes
formes en fonction des dates lieux et
échéance décidée par la constitution par
exemple le scrutin prévu le dimanche
peut commencer très bien dès le mercredi
et s'étaler du coup jusqu'à la date
officielle
alors ces votes anticipés peuvent être
effectués via une machine électronique
ou par papier par voie postale ce qui
correspond finalement au vote par
correspondance loi supprimé en 1975 et
nous avons voulu demander ce que pensent
les yvelinois du vote par anticipation
je préfère me rendre dans l'urne ou
pouvoir anticiper à plusieurs semaines
ou plusieurs mois oui parce qu'on ne
sait pas encore aujourd'hui quelles
seront les conditions sanitaires on
présente la carte
on insère la petite enveloppe une vie à
voter là c'est qu'elle cachait tout ça
maintenant moi j'aime bien ça serait
plus rapide
pour nous qui travaillons en fait en
trop et ça serait pas mal
à part pour les gestes barrière où ça
pourrait permettre justement qui ait
moins de monde dans les bureaux de vote
sinon je trouve pas ça super utile on
trafique abl on pourrait facilement
entrer chez moi ça c'est partagé il ya
aussi eu de vives réactions dans les
différentes oppositions politiques
oui oui le vote par anticipation a
suscité un tollé dans la sphère
politique
alors d'abord dans la forme par le
caractère soudain de cet amendement mais
aussi dans le fond puisque tous les
partis d'opposition sont contre écouter
on ne touche pas à la règle pendant le
processus
on est dans la dernière ligne droite de
la fin du mandat
on ne change pas les règles cette
manière là avec cette méthode sans débat
national sans débat citoyen et sans
consensus politique
comme tous les éleveurs ne sont pas
forcément au même niveau d'information
on n'est pas sûr de la qualité
d'électeur est ce que c'est bien lui qui
vote dans les élections américaines cela
suscitait un doute importante ce vote
par anticipation ne permettra pas une
transparence comme on en a l'habitude
dans la comptabilité et la vérification
des votes
je ne crois qu'il faut rien s'interdire
qu'il faut vraiment réfléchir à toutes
les pistes qu'il faut être complètement
ouvert bon je fais pas comme ça dans la
précipitation cc c'est dangereux pour la
démocratie
vous l'aurez compris il ya beaucoup de
doutes concernant le vote par
anticipation la majorité elle voulait le
mettre en place pour lutter contre
l'abstention
ça sera un obstacle levé pour les
personnes qui peuvent pas se déplacer le
dimanche il y apprend le monde et les
éléments discutable qu'on peut on peut
compenser mes parents gens ne nous
interdisons pas le débat souvent
prétexte idéologique de on est contre le
débat est maintenant ouvert en tout cas
dans la sphère publique et pour rappel
le vote par correspondance avait été
supprimé en 1975 pour réduire la fraude
électorale
questionnement est similaire pour le
vote par anticipation merci seigneur
pour toutes ces précisions et on
continue à parler de ce sujet avec mon
invité en visioconférence jean-pierre
camby bonsoir bonsoir
professeur associé à l'université
versailles saint quentin vous êtes
spécialiste du droit électoral vous avez
d'ailleurs publié dernièrement un
ouvrage sur la question électorale aux
éditions dalloz 1cet ouvrage se nomme
bureaux de vote mode d'emploi déjà
première question que pensez de cette
méthode choisie par le gouvernement pour
parler justement du vote par
anticipation celle de présenter cet
amendement au sénat alors qu'un projet
de loi avait été adoptée précédemment à
l'assemblée nationale avec cette
question du vote par anticipation qui
n'était pas abordé
c'est plutôt surprenant comme manière de
faire c'est surprenant à ton égard
puisque le départ ne peut plus avoir
lieu dans le cadre de ce texte dès lors
que le sénat a rejeté l'amendement et
qu'il y avait une procédure accélérée
le gouvernement n'a pas choisi une voie
qui serait la plus logique compte tenu
de l'importance de ce débat qui aurait
consisté à remettre dès le projet de loi
initial ce qui aurait permis un avis du
conseil d'état
une étude d'impact et s'agissant de
l'élection présidentielle on aurait pu
également demandé l'avis du conseil
constitutionnel par cette méthode le
gouvernement s'est en quelque sorte
priver d'un débat parlementaire de fond
est bien entendu le sénat a rejeté cet
amendement très majoritairement mais ça
a été dit dans la chronique précédente
et est-ce que du coup ce rejet du sénat
ça annihile totalement les chances de
voir un vote par anticipation dès
l'année prochaine des pour les
présidentielles de 2022 la réponse est
plutôt oui il ya un dispositif du code
électoral qui est l'article 5 167 1 à
qui prévoit qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
deux modalités nouvelles un an avant une
élection par modalités il faut
naturellement entendre les modalités de
vote et le découpage des
circonscriptions
c'est évidemment une disposition
législative
on pourrait passer au delà elle n'a pas
valeur constitutionnelle le conseil
constitutionnel l'a jugé mais c'est très
difficile
un an avant une échéance de venir
modifier en bouleversant à ce point les
modalités d'un vote
pourquoi pas le voir dans les prochaines
années quelle révolution cela
apporterait justement dans le droit
électoral
le fait de pouvoir mettre un vote par
anticipation aux quelques questions ça
soulève aussi finalement c'est ce serait
une méthode totalement inédite soit la
république française
j'ai entendu les personnes que vous avez
interviewé
vous voyez bien qu'elles sont toutes
attachées à la tradition au rite
républicain consistant à se rendre à
l'udm dès que vous dissocier l'urne et
les lecteurs vous rencontrez
incontestablement des problèmes ces
problèmes peuvent être de divers ordres
il peut d'abord y avoir des problèmes
techniques c'est pour ça qu'il y à un
moratoire sur les machines à voter en
france depuis 2008
il n'y a plus de nouvelles machines à
voter il ya 64 communes qui sont
équipées de machines à voter
on a dit qu'on allait pas au delà
l'amendement impliqué par exemple de
doter tous le pays de machines à voter
ce qui aurait causé des problèmes
techniques
peut-être insurmontable ce qui aurait eu
écoute qu'on ne connaissait pas
puisqu'il n'ya pas d'étude d'impact
il ya aussi l'argument qui est revenu on
l'a entendue dans le micro trottoir
peut-être aussi de menaces de fraude
est-ce que c'est aussi une des questions
qui qui est soulevée avec ce vote par
anticipation quand on voit les dernières
polémiques il ya eu notamment avec
l'élection américaine on est loin de la
france mais en tout cas ça a été
soulevée pendant cette campagne
électorale aux états unis deux éléments
de réponse le premier en france
on a pu voter par correspondance postale
entre 1946 et 1975
on a supprimé cette modalité en 1975
parce qu'elle était une incitation à la
fraude s'agissant des votes
électroniques
évidemment vous avez une intermédiation
par un technicien par une phase
technique que les lecteurs ne maîtrise
plus quant aux états unis vous voyez
bien que c'est un contre exemple pour
introduire un tel système novateur en
france puisque ça a été le seul point
technique d'ancrage qu'ont trouvé les
partisans de donald trump pour contester
l'élection mais c'est un système aussi
qu'on a pu voir ce système de vote par
anticipation également au portugal alors
il ya l'argument de la lutte contre
l'abstention qui a été avancé par le
gouvernement justement pour justifier la
mise en place d'un tel vote par
anticipation et ce qui pourrait y avoir
un effet réel sur la participation le
fait de mettre en place éventuellement
un vote par anticipation
je ne crois qu'on puisse que des contre
l'abstention par des moyens techniques
la réponse à la rétention elle est à
bord politique
elle est dans le fait que les électeurs
aient envie de se rendre aux urnes
comprennent les enjeux
regardez les taux de participation
extrêmement faible aux dernières
élections législatives
le l'abstentéisme a franchi des records
ils ne sont pas liés à une technique de
vote donc mettre en avant la situation
sanitaire actuelle qui peut poser des
problèmes que le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs plutôt bien gérée en
augmentant par exemple les possibilités
en ouvrant les possibilités de vote par
procuration est une bonne chose
aller au delà en bouleversant une fois
encore le rituel républicain ne
paraîtrait extrêmement dangereux et on
l'a compris en tout cas un peu de
chances de le voir aboutir pour l'année
prochaine on verra pour les autres
années il ya une autre question qui
pourrait revenir aussi sur la table on
met de côté ce vote
par par anticipation ceci le scrutin à
la proportionnelle qui pourrait faire
son retour
on en avait entendu parler lors de la
dernière campagne des présidentielles
bientôt aussi sur la table merci jean
pierre camby d'avoir répondu à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
professeur associé à lui fait est-ce qu
également du coup spécialiste du droit
électoral je rappelle aussi un cet
ouvrage que vous avez publié
dernièrement aux éditions est dalloz
bureaux de vote
mode d'emploi est les derniers
indicateurs du coc vite 19 dans les
yvelines avec des chiffres de
contamination qui sont à la hausse sur
une semaine
+17 points pour le taux d'incidence
c'est à dire le nombre de nouvelles
personnes contaminées pour 100000
habitants le taux de positivité au test
est également en légère hausse du côté
des hôpitaux le nombre de patients est
en baisse - 40 dans les yvelines sur une
semaine 55 personnes et étiez en
réanimation dans le département donné
elle qui est en hausse depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire et 1336 décès liés
aux copies 19 ont été enregistrés dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois ce déplacement en
fin de semaine dernière jean baptiste
djebbari à s'est rendu au mobile app sur
le plateau de satory à versailles le
ministre délégué aux transports a visité
les locaux de transdev et devait d comme
deux acteurs engagés dans le
développement du véhicule autonome et de
son écosystème
le secteur est en plein essor avec des
premières expérimentations sur route les
détails dans ce sujet de nicolas landry
voici i cristal le véhicule autonome
développé par transdev et ses
partenaires cette navette fonctionnant à
l'énergie électrique a vocation à
intégrer le transport public
une première expérimentation à route
ouverte devrait débuter à rouen en 2022
avant un déploiement commercial d'ici à
une cinquantaine de personnes
travaillent sur ce projet à satory vous
voyez derrière moi des binard des radars
nous avons des caméras et derrière il ya
un logiciel qui fait la perception de
l'environnement et dessine des
traducteurs en suivant c'est dans ce
contexte que jean baptiste djebbari
ministre délégué en charge des
transports a visité le site de satory
tout
un écosystème autour de la mobilité
autonome des activités allant de la
collecte de données au développement
technologique pour permettre le suivi et
la supervision du véhicule autonome nos
comportements sur la route comme piéton
et comme conducteurs sont souvent basées
sur le contrat qu'on se donne à chacun
la perception de ce que va faire l'autre
est ce qu'on anticipait évidemment avec
une machine il faut repenser les
protocoles de communication finalement
entre entre l'humain et la machine mais
c'est tout ça qui s'observent et si sur
le plan traits cognitifs et c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs d'avoir fait
l'expérience cameron sur le simulateur
véhicule ce simulateur piétons
en plus des technologies et des
compétences numériques d'autres
connaissances sont nécessaires pour le
développement du véhicule autonome
c'est une partie de l'activité devait d
comme c'est aussi une innovation qui est
appelle des compétences en matière de
comportement de science cognitive
d'ergonomie car il ya une grande
dimension humaine dans ce domaine de
l'eau multi autonome avec son simulateur
automobile bd comme travaille aussi à
partir de son simulateur pour les
piétons des expérimentations qui permet
d'étudier le comportement face à la
mobilité autonome c'est savoir si les
personnes ont un comportement différent
dans la traversée de route face à un
véhicule autonome où il va y avoir
personne derrière le volant on a pu
observer également que si on utilise des
systèmes interactifs pour donner l'état
du véhicule à savoir des messages
simples genre je circule
je m'arrête je patiente je démarre dans
ces cas là la personne est plus en
confiance et va opérer une traversée de
route ou là ou alors hésité malgré la
crise sanitaire bd comme a déposé une
quinzaine de projets d'investissements
d'avenir et une quinzaine de projets
européens avec comme objectif
d'accélérer la décarbonisation et la
digitalisation de la mobilité dans le
reste de l'actualité une semaine après
les incidents de poissy de nouvelles
scènes de violence dans les yvelines
samedi des faits ont été relevés au
moins dans neuf communes du département
où les forces de l'ordre ont été prises
à partie tirs de mortiers jets de
projectiles ou encore outrage huit
personnes en tout ont été interpellés
dans le week end une à sartrouville 5 à
guyancourt pour des dégradations de
véhicules et de opecst pour refus de
contrôle suite au non respect du
couvre-feu direction trappe à présent
pas de polémique mais une réponse suite
à l'emballement
médiatique autour des propos du
professeur de philosophie didier lemaire
le rappeur kirtas a écrit une chanson
est tourné un clip pour redonner une
image positive de la ville le reportage
d'eléonore sinoquet de patrick jacques
de dixmude tout ça trappe
[Musique]
c'est la réponse dans saint quentinois à
l'emballement médiatique des dernières
semaines autour de trappes
le rappeur kirtas a tourné un clip ce
week end devant le lycée de la plaine de
neuf établissements où enseignait didier
lemaire le professeur de philosophie qui
a fait polémique en dénonçant l'emprise
communautaire dans la ville les gens ne
connaissent pas trappe ils entendent
malheureusement beaucoup de négatif
elle a l'idée après et après l'appel des
scènes d'amour yaba c'était d'aller un
peu plus loin et d'écrire une chanson
entière
le rap que chez ces véhiculer des
messages et j'ai toujours été dans ce
côté-là d'espoir l'entr'aide et le vivre
ensemble
si son morceau qu'il a écrit très
rapidement après la polémique veut
redorer l'image de trappes que retard
n'en reste pas moins lucide sur la
situation de la colonne on est conscient
qu'il ya certains problèmes mais ces
problèmes là justement il faut je pense
essayer de trouver des solutions sans
comment dire sans forcément taper du
doigt à longueur de journée parce que ça
on n'avance pas le rappeur n'est pas
originaire de la ville mais kirtas n'a
pas été choisi au hasard pour écrire
cette chanson c ur ya une habitante qui
l'a sollicité pour revaloriser l'image
de sa commune
yao rire qui m'appelle encore une fois
sa ville est sous le feu des projecteurs
pas pour dire quel était il a toujours
participé aux événements de la commune
donc pour moi c'était c'était une
évidence ça j'adore ces écritures il a
il a des mots plutôt assez simple et
puis en même temps les le message qu'il
véhicule auprès des jeunes correspond
parfaitement
donc bien sûr c'est un peu comme une
évidence pour moi le clip de kurt a
ainsi que la chanson sortiront mercredi
24 février sur sa chaîne youtube un
morceau qu'il espère voir partager le
plus précision europe c'est la culture
la mixité tous unis pour trouver des
solutions
on rigole bien nos blagues de djamel de
sourire ton marcy grandement nous pousse
tu es comme l'a dit le coran abd al
malik en a qui t'ont fait plus deux avec
une forêt qui pousse la mobilisation de
coignières concernant l'habitat la
commune va mettre en place prochainement
des logements dits de priorités sociales
un lieu d'accueil pour permettre aux
familles en difficulté de trouver une
solution temporaire d'hébergement le
tout sur la base d'une convention
d'occupation précaire de trois mois
renouvelable une fois
en plus du logement les résidents
pourront bénéficier d'un accompagnement
social adapté proposées par le ccas de
la commune du sport pour refermer ce
journal ce week-end lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines accueillait
les championnats de france de cyclo
cross
la compétition a réuni les à catégorie à
cadets juniors et masters à huit clos
dans le contexte de la crise sanitaire
retour sur cet événement avec mickaël
millero et patrick jacques de dixmude la
fédération française de cyclisme a
réussi son pari les championnats de
france cadets juniors et masters sont pu
se tenir ce dimanche 21 février sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
malgré le contexte sanitaire et
l'annulation de la plupart des courses
en france
quand on a compris qu'on ne pourrait pas
le faire tenir en même temps que le
championnat de france élite qui était
tout
début janvier à pontchâteau et on avait
pris l'engagement de vraiment tout faire
pour essayer d'organiser un championnat
c'est avec beaucoup de bonheur qu'on a
reçu l'autorisation de la préfecture il
ya huit jours pour pouvoir tenir
effectivement ce championnat l'événement
s'est tenu à huis clos avec un protocole
sanitaire une jauge maximale de 500
personnes en simultané était également
mise en place des règles strictes qui
n'ont pas contrarié les 550 coureurs
venus des quatre coins de la france les
cyclistes présents n'ont pas boudé leur
plaisir de recourir après cette saison
de cyclo-cross bouleversé j'ai pas fait
un cross de la saison
donc parce que ça a été compliqué c'est
vrai que là ça va être la salle de
servette la salle c'est la seule
compétition pour l'instant à laquelle on
a eu droit donc
c'était un objectif c'est un objectif de
l'année ça a été annulée reportée donc
bah voilà on est au rendez vous ce que
je garderai c'est simplement quand les
jeunes hier passer à côté de moi le long
de la ligne
le simplement le fait de dire merci et
sourire on avait déjà gagné notre
week-end sur le plan sportif c'est 550
courant du se dépasser pour atteindre
leur objectif une boucle de 2 7 km
autour du centre équestre de l'île de
loisirs avait été imaginé ils apportent
vraiment tout ce qui est dans cette
discipline vous avez de la technique
vous avez des parties roulantes
vous allez partout il faut de la force
si vous connaître la trajectoire
début des parties où il faut porter du
vélo ici on surligne l'agir de 50 ans on
est vraiment sur le territoire du cyclo
cross le succès rencontré par cet
événement malgré la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs espèrent désormais
organiser un championnat de france élite
de cyclo cross à l'horizon 2024 elle ce
sujet et d'autres encore développé dans
un instant avec l'émission le 7-8 sport
s'est présentée par michael et demi
d'euros voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]